la situación epidemiológica en indian no
da tregua el país superó el récord
mundial de contagios diarios por cuarto
día consecutivo el ministerio de salud
indio reportó 349 mil 691 nuevos
contagios y 2.767 muertes en 24 horas en
total el país de 1.300 millones de
habitantes acumula más de 192.000
fallecidos por kobe 19
y hoy me dirijo a ustedes a través de
este programa mientras que el
coronavirus pone a prueba nuestra
paciencia y pone a prueba nuestra
capacidad de soportar el dolor muchas de
nuestras personas cercanas y seres
queridos nos dejaron prematuramente amén
hasta mayor galega
en delhi y alrededor del territorio los
hospitales están colapsados sin camas
disponibles y sin reservas de oxígeno
por un lado países como el vecino
bangladesh y otros como alemania italia
o maldivas han suspendido la entrada de
viajeros desde india pero por otro lado
la comunidad internacional se moviliza
para apoyar al país ya anunciaron su
colaboración
pakistán singapur la unión europea o
eeuu que mandará oxígeno y materias
primas para la fabricación de vacunas y
el reino unido- cifró en 600 los
elementos que enviara incluyendo
ventiladores y concentradores de oxígeno
haremos una serie de envíos el primero
saldrá hoy estamos discutiendo con el
gobierno de indios sobre sus necesidades
queremos ofrecerles todo nuestro apoyo
porque somos buenos amigos pero también
porque necesitamos esta clase de
colaboración internacional si queremos
salir de la pandemia no estaremos a
salvo hasta que todos estemos a salvo
sin embargo el ministro de exteriores
británico sostuvo que el envío de
vacunas es una discusión paralela el
país asiático golpeado por una segunda
ola
se ha visto particularmente afectado por
la aparición de una nueva variante
conocida como be 1 617 y calificada de
doble mutación que ha disparado la
cantidad de positivos